[Music]
hello everyone I'm adren are you Rick
I'm the product director in Google
Cloud's data analytics team
hi everyone I'm Sanjay Chaudhary I'm VPO
product management at exaby
today we will be talking about real-time
analytics for continuous intelligence
you'll get an opportunity to see how to
get started at a very low risk free
Workshop offers and we'll have questions
and answers with Sanjay on how they
built their services on Google clouds
so let's start with this
various studies are showing that by the
end of 2024 75 of the Enterprises will
shift from piloting to operationalizing
artificial intelligence which will drive
400 increase in streaming data analytics
on infrastructures all this is coming
from the data that you're dealing with
either in your iot devices or your media
databases wherever this data is on the
right hand side of the slide you see the
peak of the value that is the highest as
the event is happening so objective is
to be able to respond during the short
window and get the fastest insight to
the right person that event becomes part
of the Mountain of knowledge and used
later on but how you respond in that
short window is really important for
streaming Analytics
building the backbone for this
continuous enjoy Innovation is key
today's challenges are well a lot of
these disconnected data's siled really
not working well together tools High
latency inelastic situations whether
it's your compute or your storage
whatever and more importantly a lot of
hand holding in these Technologies
but are truly unified batching streaming
Technologies for continuous intelligence
brings you the automated Solutions the
insights when you need them and truly
elastic highly managed truly managed and
new for all your digital business models
and we have proven use cases across
every industry from Healthcare to
manufacturing to retail to Telco to
fintech every one of them have been
taking advantage of these Technologies
and bringing use cases and later on we
will be talking with Sanjay on what they
are doing at exabeam
these Technologies were born out of
Google research with over 15 years in
production this is at Google scale it's
real time when you need it proven at
scale at Google scale and truly unified
batch and streaming
Forester CI report a third party
have studied with customers and
discovered all these customers have seen
55 percent developer productivity when
they adopted data flow near 50 of
infrastructure costs reduction and all
of this less than six months of payback
time massive Roi for your business
here are some examples from many
Industries who have adopted data flow
and how they benefited from it the great
example from media customers before data
flow they were not using streaming
analytics and now almost 50 percent of
all their new jobs built on streaming
because that is their job that's their
industry you can actually see it and in
the financial systems and Bank
Industries you can actually see the
example over there when they adopted it
they were able to turn around the
results much faster for their Industries
for their customers many to side in here
thousands of customers great use cases
these are sponsors and provided with
these Technologies in real time
streaming technologies that we brought
in from Google's native Technologies you
capture the value you capture the data
as you ingest as you process under a
second all these exactly was delivery
that you needed for use cases apply the
insights into your dashboards many of
you are actually doing these reverse
etls with ML inferences and achieving
continuous intelligences all the time
for your businesses
single implementation to help you cross
the bridge from where you are today to
where you want to be it's very low risk
and off the bat you can actually get 10
reduction on your costs
even if you just sat with your with your
batch workloads today
and it is future proof as you move into
the real-time analytics you can actually
see the streaming value and of achieve
over 50 percent of cost savings
in the meantime you're actually
improving the productivity of all your
engineers because there is no ritualing
there is no parallel infrastructure this
is truly unified batch and streaming API
in one model highly automated
it is different from Kafka it is
different from Kinesis it is different
from event hubs it's born out of Google
research with over 15 years of
production scale at Google scale
Readiness for you made them available to
easy deployment at scale for your
businesses
thousands of customers are in production
today across all Industries and many use
cases
no Ops truly fully managed by Google so
that you can actually focus on your own
business and your own use cases when it
comes to data Google is the leader it is
the industry leaders whether it's the
data warehousing or the streaming
analytics when it comes to data
the unique industry-leading architecture
this Google native Technologies from
pops up to data flow to bigquery to
vertex AI is built on Google
infrastructure and we are working with
every digital leader and transforming
every Enterprise worldwide
you may be wondering how you can start
it well we have free hack Fest style
workshops you may be wondering what is
this hack Quest well it's a two hours of
content we will help you demo provide
you deep Dives we will work with your
use cases and whatever the use case
might be if we have a Hands-On we'll
actually show you how that worked in a
different industry what do you get from
it you demonstrate your own use cases on
gcp access and training to a massive new
offering and maybe you'll accelerate one
of your Pilots that you were thinking
about it and most importantly it's free
if you're interested in taking advantage
of the hack Fest please sign up contact
your uh reps this will help you
demonstrate your use cases on gcp get
access to training new offering
accelerate to Pilot and it's free many
of our customers have taken advantage of
it let's hear from Sanjay the VP of XI
beam welcome please tell us a bit about
yourself
hi everyone I'm Sanjay I'm VPO product
management at exabeam I'm also
responsible for identifying right
technology stack for extra beam cyber
security platform
now talking a little bit about exabeam
exabeam is a leader in Gartner's magic
quadrant for Sim we are also a leader in
Forester wave for security Analytics we
have been a leader for last three years
in a row one of the unique value
proposition of excel beam in which
differentiate us from other vendors is
machine learning and behavioral
analytics based threat detection and
incident response which allow our
customers to understand Normal and
abnormal behavior across petabytes of
data without making any changes to their
security tooling so tell us about your
current data strategy and product
management at exabeam
I'm going to talk about that as you see
exabeam is running fully serverless
capabilities so we are focused on
serverless infrastructure which includes
serverless storage analysis ingestion
processing now being serverless allows
us to focus more on security and less on
data and allows us to deliver High scale
high performance and and high
availability to our customers with this
platform exabeam and Google Cloud have
enjoyed a great partnership to dates and
what does that mean for you and your
company how did Google partner with you
how did it help exabean's Journey
yeah Google cloud is one of the best
place to run big data and Analytics
workloads in fact Google cloud is
powering our Cloud scale cyber security
platform
Google is helping us deliver
Limitless EPS ingestion it is also
helping us deliver search and detection
capabilities on multi-year data and
helps us to provide our customers Data
Insights in minutes so Google cloud is
definitely one of the core components of
our platform helping us deliver great
scale and performance to our customers
so we talked about unified batching
streaming and your team truly built that
for your business yes and let's talk
about those real-time insights and how
you're doing it how you're taking
advantage of it because your business
needs this and we're truly uh thankful
that you're actually doing it for all
the industries
yeah no I think the data flow is a is a
very unique product to be honest with
you I was introduced to Apache beam
after learning about dataflow because I
was really interviewed by some of the
capabilities we are discussing on this
slide so data flow is is a product which
has no other capability matching in the
market compared to this product and I'll
talk a little bit about our experience
because we have been on this journey for
long enough to understand the
capabilities and we have compared every
other vendor in the market
now first thing you talked about unified
batch and stream why is that important
for example if I write a code which runs
on data flow integrated with Pub sub for
real time uh processing I can use the
same source code and run on bigquery for
batch jobs so you don't have to change
that program it when you write once and
you can run it both the streaming and
batch
traditionally
people would have used two separate
Technologies probably spark for your
batch ingestion and Flink for your
stream ingestion
the other thing which we don't talk a
lot about is is reduction in amount of
code written so when my team has started
doing POC on dataflow I asked them to
replicate some of the work they were
doing on the spark and I was surprised a
thousand long line of code was converted
into just 100 lines of code with data
flow so so this is this is definitely
helping our data science and and and and
important Engineers to spend more time
writing efficient code rather than
writing a code which is just to manage
spark clusters
the third thing is machine learning at
scale which is very close to exabeam's
heart and data flow is one of the unique
capabilities which allows us to process
millions of events per second
no other product can come as close to
the performance we have seen in with
data flow in terms of a scale of
processing machine learning jobs
now there's a unique situation which is
very specific to us is handling late
arriving events right so when you create
a session window
and you based on that session you want
to take some decisions and very
important events were are arriving late
they don't arrive in that specific
session window what do you do about it
so data flow is one of the unique
Technologies where you can easily handle
these late arriving events and
re-re-score your models which have been
previously scored without these events
so very very powerful in terms of
handling late arriving event last but
not the least if you have highly paid
data science team members you don't want
to them to spend 50 of their Time
Babysitting the spark cluster this is
the right technology that lets our data
science team focus on the data science
jobs awesome so great to hear thank you
well these were the obvious ones let's
talk about not so obvious benefits that
you've seen from data flow of during
your journey
yeah I think there are there are many
not so obvious benefits which I would
like to highlight based on our
experience with data flow first thing I
would like to talk about the the what I
call the non-functional benefits you can
take take an example of configuration
pushing a configuration to data flow job
is so easy error handling it's have
native capabilities to easily handle
errors and it smoothly handles those
errors our local developments where you
can run a beam direct runner for local
development on dataflow but what are the
three most important non-obvious
benefits I would say the number one is
observability so when you go inside data
flow UI it gives you a full visibility
of the data flow pipeline every stage of
your pipeline so you can see at what
stage data flow is doing what when you
click at any of these nodes at right
hand side navigation pops up where you
can see every metrics related to that
processing job which is really really
unique capability with this product so
observability is definitely on top of my
mind
second thing is cost
we are a security product developer so
we provide these products to many
customers as a SAS application so for us
having a linear cost model is very
important what do I mean by linear if
you have used traditional products you
would know that they have certain cost
when you're running at a small scale and
this cost when you go at a higher scale
the cost is let's say if you're paying
for one GB of data processing with the
traditional product one dollar when you
go to 100 it's not 100 sometimes 200 it
could be 300 because as your cluster
size increases a lot of nodes in the
cluster gets busy managing each other
rather than doing your job and this is
where we were really impressed with data
flow that the cost of processing 1GB of
data if it's costing me one dollar when
the job goes to a terabytes is going to
linearly cost me a thousand dollars it's
not going to go beyond that linear
capacity last but not the least is
multi-tenancy so the multi-stream
architecture data flow have which allow
me to parameterize every pipeline for
every tenant so which allows me to build
a single pair Pipeline and parameterize
it and run it differently for different
different tenants it's really important
for us because we would like to offer
each of our customers a different
machine learning and advanced analytics
model and processing capabilities so
these are some of the non-obvious
benefits I would say thank you that was
fantastic and I'm sure a lot out there
are wondering in your roles these
leaders who are trying to transform
their Industries becoming digital
leaders
so what would you recommend how do how
should they approach what would you say
to those leaders yeah so being part of
Google's customer Advisory Board gives
me access to a lot of large Fortune 500
companies so I would say there are two
schools of thought especially if you're
a large company any Cloud transformation
or data transformation journey is going
to be long it's not going to be so fast
as we were able to do with exabeam any
roadblocks to our growth we handle it
from CEO to every developer at a rapid
speed so we were able to
go on this journey and finish this
journey rapidly but for larger companies
definitely you have to think about your
different different organization silos
and how you bring these shadow teams
together regardless of size of the
company I have three very important
recommendation for anybody thinking
about Cloud transformation or or are
doing a database transformation which
has huge impact on the company first is
think 10x scale at least 10x scale if
you're running in your operations at 10
petabytes of scale think about 100
petabytes don't go from 10 to 12 or 15
and a good example for our industry is
when if you look at 10 years back the
anti-virus is like McAfee and semantic
we're sending 10 GB or 20 GB of data
to the Sim providers today's antiviruses
are I would call them EDR players like
card strike and Sentinel one send 10 15
terabytes of data per day and it's
pretty normal so don't get stuck in a
technology stack which you have to
reinvent every five years Focus long
term at least have 10 10x scale second
very controversial is a lot of data
products have been built for on-premise
ecosystem so I will start with Kafka
spark mongodb
and Presto many of these Technologies
including elasticsearch were built long
back for on-premise workloads so when
you bring these Technologies on the
cloud you will have to spend a lot of
time managing these Technologies so when
you're restarting your Cloud Journey
think about serverless capabilities
think about Cloud native capabilities
like bigquery and data flow to start
your journey
last and the most uh important thing is
cost right Cloud transformation is not
just about massive scale capabilities
you can offer to your customers but you
also have to run your business
profitably what I've seen is cost of
ownership and time to Market these are
very important aspects for for us as a
startup and Cloud products definitely
help you with that first no doubt about
the time to Market but the cost of
ownership let's take an example of
something like spark right when you go
to a massive data scale processing
Pipeline with this spark it takes you
months to to mature versus it takes you
weeks with data flow so don't ignore the
total cost of ownership don't ignore
your time to Market especially if you're
a startup like us and Cloud native
products will help you more in that
direction thank you for everything thank
you for this Rich conversation and your
insights and looking forward to seeing
huge huge success with you Sanjay thank
you so much great partnership thanks
[Music]